just look at this here fish there's
nothing else like it it's blind it has
huge fins that look like wings and it
quacks but not the way other walking
fish move those guys walk by hopping
forward using their pectoral fins like
crutches this cave fish actually takes
steps it moves one fin in front of the
other like a really awkward lizard that
slow March could teach us a lot about
how our own fishy ancestors learn how to
walk this waterfall climbing a fish is
incredibly rare though it lives in just
eight caves in the world and the thai
government fiercely protects the species
so American scientists studying the
thing had to rely on these videos shot
by a scientist showing the weird walking
they also developed a 3d model of the
fish using a CT scan of a specimen kept
at a time use ium
thanks to high-resolution camcorders CT
scanners and skyping scientists the
world has one more super weird fish -
ooh and aah over